[Applaudissements]
depuis mon doctorat en sciences
cognitives où j'ai étudié le chaos
neuronale je me pose une question
comment est-ce que les 10 milliards de
neurones qui composent mon cerveau
arrive est le vôtre s'ils arrivent à
engendrer ce qu'il ya de plus noble dans
la création humaine c'est la pensée et à
gérer mon corps comme ça entre eux sans
qu'il y ait de chef sans qu'il y ait de
l'hiérarchie sans qu'il y ait de réunion
sans qu'il y ait de neurones validé iso
ou d'autres noms ils font ensemble
simplement en étant en confiance par une
règle qui a été édictée en 1949 qui
s'appelle la règle de haybes qui est et
ben si on fait la même chose on renforce
nos clients c'est ça qui était assez
impressionnant et je me demande
aujourd'hui dans quelle mesure ce type
de principe qui est si efficace dans le
vivant pourrait être appliquée à nos
sociétés si ça pourrait inspirer
peut-être de nouveaux modes de
fonctionnement
prenons ce qui existe aujourd'hui
l'ordre qui existe et qui est assez
bizarre qui est qu' on a l'impression
que tout est naturel tout existe quand
on arrive au monde il y a des usines il
ya du travail il y à des banques
il y a des
les universités pour nous fournir des
diplômes il y à la loi qui est là et si
on y réfléchit c'est assez bizarre parce
que un travail souvent on s'identifie
par le rôle qu'on a je suis un notaire
je suis un avocat mais par personne
neutre pour la banque
on est quand même en train de se
combattre pour des bouts de papier
imprimé qu'on met dans des coffres et
que l'on défense en combattant pour les
diplômes d'imaginer que simplement par
un titre ça va valider toutes mes
compétences pour tout le long de ma vie
et pour la loi que en permanence on va
créer de nouvelles lois que je suis
censé ne pas ignorer mais qui devient
sans cesse et sans cesse plus complexe
tout ça c'est bizarre si on y réfléchit
vraiment mais ça nous semble naturel
parce qu'un bizarre auquel on s'est
habitué eh ben c'est ça qui nous semble
naturel et donc habitué à ça parce que
depuis notre plus tendre enfance
eh bien on nous a formés à ça à cette
compétition à cette idée que il fallait
avoir un bon métier qu'il fallait avoir
un bon diplôme qu'il fallait avoir de
l'argent combas toutes nos valeurs
dessus eh bien on va se battre les uns
contre les autres
rentrer en concurrence parce que les
places sont rares jusqu'à arriver pour
les meilleurs d'entre nous en eau ou la
saint graal on commence à avoir du
pouvoir
le problème du pouvoir ceux qui ne se
partage pas vraiment si j'ai du pouvoir
et que je donne à tout le monde je perds
un peu celui que j'avais donc il va
falloir une certaine façon défendre ce
pouvoir selon en utilisant tous les
mécanismes qui font que l'on va
maintenir le système dans l'état dans
lequel il est c'est ce qu'on appelle les
forces de l'ordre d'une certaine façon
c'est on va classer les gens par
frontières on va les classer par métier
on va imposer tel et tel système pour
que surtout ça ne change pas trop et par
un enfermement permanent on arrive à
cette idée ce principe d un pour cent
qui vont se refermer sur eux en
utilisant tout le pouvoir qu'ils peuvent
avoir
voilà un monde bizarre mais étant formé
à ça et ans éduqué à ça on va tous le
reproduire on va rentrer dans nos
structures dans nos métiers et on va
reproduire ces hiérarchies
on va reproduire tous ces grands
principes tout simplement parce qu'ils
nous sont importants et surtout on va
les défendre parce qu on a fait
tellement d'efforts pour ça souvent on
justifie la valeur des choses non pas
par le bien-être qu'elle nous apporte
mais par les efforts qu'on a consenti et
plus on a fait d'efforts plus on va
l'imposer aux autres parce qu'il n'y a
pas de raison que les autres ne fassent
pas cet effort là prenons quelques
exemples dans notre monde actuel
imaginons tout simplement quelqu'un qui
veut travailler travailler ça consiste
en quoi c'est pas avoir un contrat assez
justes et bien échangé une compétence
contre une rémunération pour ça il va
falloir qu'ils s'adaptent à la loi du
travail au code du travail aux lois qui
lie à pour obtenir le diplôme par
exemple à numerus clausus en médecine
comme la concurrence est rude il va
falloir sans doute qu'il aille voir son
banquier faire après banquiers qui va
donc l'autorisé sont prêts il va ensuite
pouvoir être préparés pour passer un
concours d'une école qui au bout d'un
moment va lui donner un diplôme valable
de toute éternité qui sera transmis à
l'entreprise et qui lui confiera
peut-être un travail mais on a oublié un
lien c'est que ce qu'on voulait faire ce
que cette personne voulait faire c'était
juste ça échanger avec quelqu'un d'autre
une compétence contre une rémunération
on l'a oublié et autres risques
tentation évidemment puisqu'on a perdu
le contrôle c'est que il semblerait que
certaines universités peuvent vendre des
diplômes factice ou que lorsque l'on est
entre nous on peut
obtenir une rémunération sans qu'il y
ait véritable travail mais je n'en dirai
pas plus imaginons maintenant deux
personnes transaction classique je veux
vendre ma maison
qu'est ce que je dois faire et bien je
dois tout simplement contacter un
banquier puis un notaire qui est
l'expert de l'art banquiers qui va
demander à mon employeur mes fiches de
paye a ainsi que mon contrat de travail
afin de proposer à un contre un ensuite
un autre notaire sera contacté qui va
contacter le premier pour va le voir
voir s'ils m'ont montré est bien
acceptée dès lors qu'il est accepté il
va pouvoir rédiger l'acte de propriété
qui sera transmis à l'autre et enfin
l'autre devient propriétaire là encore
tout ce qu'on voulait faire c'était ça
avec de nouveaux risques
une préemption sur la maison que je
pensais vendre ou autres risques avec la
loi qui a évolué depuis 2016 de saisie
sur mon compte si elle fait faillite
autres et d'autres tentations évidemment
qu'ils peuvent être d'obtenir des prêts
à taux préférentiels dès lors qu'on
procurent quelques avantages mais je
n'en dirai pas plus ça se passe
peut-être autour de nous autre exemple
je veux faire une entreprise avec un ami
et bien tout d'abord il va nous falloir
un diplôme un parce que sans diplôme ça
va être difficile
puis éventuellement poser un brevet qui
va être consulté par un commissaire aux
apports qui ensuite il va falloir faire
des retraits monétaire pour pouvoir
créer le capital qui va être déposée sur
un compte à ce moment là je pourrai
faire appel à des experts qui vont
certifié mon entreprise est ensuite
lorsqu'elle commencera à tourner je
ferai appel à d'autres experts qu'ils
s'occuperont des document cerfa et de
régler les taxes que je dois en
permanence
oui mais tout ce qu'on voulait c'était
travailler ensemble ainsi voici quelques
exemples de situations qu'on a accepté
qu'ils sont difficiles qui justifie de
l'effort mais qu'on va argumenter parce
que justement on fait des efforts pour
ça et qu'on y arrive
je ne critique pas plus que ça parce que
ça fait le succès de tout notre société
on a construit beaucoup de choses par
rapport à ça il ya peut-être des moyens
pour penser autrement
ah oui avec des tentations aussi dans ce
cadre là qu'ils ont que qui sont
peut-être une entreprise ça ne se fait
pas mais ça s'hérite ou dans un autre
cas que bien conseillés par des experts
internationaux
je peux peut-être contourner les lois
qui contraignent les autres et au final
qu'est ce qu'on a fabriqué on n'a pas
fort etc et du travail de l'argent ou
ainsi de suite on a fabriqué de la donne
et du document on a toutes informatisées
on a tout automatiser et ces données qui
nous concerne mon travail mes
compétences
ma monnaie en argent tout ce que je sais
faire j'en ai confié les clés aux autres
à la société ce n'est plus moi qui les
contrôlent ce est ce sont les
spécialistes je suis comme un petit
enfant quelque part et ne nous et on
n'aime pas à avoir automatisé à avoir
formalisé toute cette connaissance que
nous soyons remplacé par peut-être désir
ou des robots et que nous perdions notre
travail
évidemment on le sent tous tout ça se
désagrège et par exemple pour la banque
la monnaie on sait qu'il ya 2 126 mille
milliards de dette au niveau mondial que
pour le travail à du turn over que pour
les diplômes les gens se forment
maintenant à l'extérieur et que pour la
loi on y comprend plus grand chose
même les spécialistes les documents
circulent dans les entreprises
il se lève en d'entre elles est ce qui
fait que tout ça ça ne se désagrège que
l'information et les on ne sait pas ou
que les gens perdre les repères et on se
retrouve dans une situation extrêmement
complexe
petit espoir c'est henri laborit qui
disait l'ordre ne peut naître de l'ordre
ne peut naître que du désordre parce que
c'est le désordre permet des
associations nouvelle et justement n'est
peut-être dans une phase où il ya des
associations nouvelles affaires et un
ordre ici pour cela il faudrait ses clés
qu'on a disséminé se les réapproprier
pour donner du sens au monde et devenir
responsable de toutes les informations
qui gère notre vie et le faire
absolument pour chacun à ce moment là
comme chacun est identifié on peut
écrire dans un document en certifiant
que c'est nous qui l'avons bien écrit
une nouvelle technologie est sorti très
pertinentes qui fait qu' on peut encoder
ce document leur présenter sous forme
d'une clé et l'encoder dans un document
un bloc à suivre et ainsi de suite
j'ai cité le terme de blog c'est ce
qu'on appelle la blocs chaîne et qui a
un gros gros avantage c'est que elle
permet de façon ouverte d'écrire en
certifiant qui en est l'auteur de façon
un falsifiable et sans qu'il y ait aucun
tiers de confiance sept blocs chaîne à
l'appareil pour la monnaie mais elle
apparaît aussi pour nous donner elle
apparaît aussi parce qu'on peut stocker
autre chose que de l'information sur la
loi et sur ce qu'on appelle des contrats
qui sont des smart contracte avec ses
stars contracte et bien on peut échanger
2 à 2 comme nos neurones et l'homme
occupe la place qu'il a tout le temps
possible occupé le centre de son univers
reprenons l'exemple des changes et une
maison de vendre une maison
je passe un contrat avec l'acheteur le
smart contracte vérifie que l'argent a
été viré
l'acte de propriété et modifie dans la
blanche n est c'est fait si j'ai besoin
d'un prêt il y à des services qui sont
possibles qui vont permettre d'obtenir
l'argent et par le contrat que je
signerai avec ce service
la structure sera remboursé internet des
objets un contrat peut être passé entre
deux objets par exemple qu'entre mon
radiateur et un panneau de cellules
photovoltaïques qui font que ils vont
échanger de la monnaie entre les deux
pourrait changer de la lumière contre de
la chaleur c'est à l'étude actuellement
par exemple autre chose on peut fonder
des projets ensemble
si l'on finance ensemble une blocs
chaîne monétaire ça s'appelle une icéo
et bien on va pouvoir créer de la
monnaie qu'on utilisera entre nous et
avec cette monnaie financer l'achat de
voitures si je veux circuler je passe un
contrat avec la voiture et si je suis
content du trajet le débit est
automatiquement fait sur mon compte
s'il ya une panne eh bien je vais
demander à quelqu'un de la réparer donc
un utilisateur
je vais faire passer un contrat avec
quelqu'un pour le réparer et pour savoir
si c'est bien fait je demanderai à
quelqu'un d'autre et les deux seront
rémunérés
tout ça se faisant automatiquement comme
mes petits neurones en échange
simplement 2 à 2 pour valider une
compétence et bien je passe un contrat
où je fais appel à un ensemble de
personnes pour leur demander est ce que
j'ai bien fait l'ensemble de ces
personnes votent et le vote dominant
sera retenu en renforçant la pertinence
de cette personne et mon incompétence
sera inscrite encore dans ce système et
ceux qui auront bien voter seront
récompensés et gagneront comme ça à eux
mêmes en compétences pour me juger
de la même façon cet apprentissage pour
être transmis à un bot ou une ia qui
apprendra dessus pour la santé et c'est
en train de se passer on va stocker
toutes nos données individuelles donc
autant pas les délégués aux autres parce
que ça me concerne et que les assurances
ne puisse pas le voir pour ensuite
consulté des ia qui peut faire des
analyses sur des millions de personnes
en même temps
le tout seconde et par des
professionnels qui vont me faire des
recommandations
et ensuite autre avantage vous me direz
pour financer tout ça c'est que il ya
des projets de monet là dessus on peut
rémunérer tout le monde par les gains de
productivité qui sont faits et obtenir
du dividende universel
ainsi on change on a un nouveau modèle
de société où les choses sont remis à
plat et dans nos différences dans nos
initiatives individuelles on se tissent
2 à 2 un peu comme des neurones ont créé
nos monnaies ont créé nos compétences
nos savoirs rond créneau ce matin
contracte nos lois ont créé notre
travail ensemble et tout ça c'est ce
qu'on appelle une des centrales ariste
autonomous organization aussi a plaidé à
eau
et ce faisant on crée tous les éléments
qui constituent ça et là on est une
société radicalement bottom up qui peut
toucher 100 % des individus pour finir
et bien ça c'est par un peu nos modèles
de société en deux comme la ville a fait
en séparant notre hémisphère gauche de
l'hémisphère droit l'hémisphère gauche
c'est l'hémisphère plus paternaliste
autour du cadre de l'organisation de la
règle de la contrainte de l'effort du
mérite et le droit c'est celui qui est
plus maternelle autour de la curiosité
de la liberté de l'an viii et ainsi de
suite et on a les deux modèles de
société qui sont irréconciliables mais
comme la ville a fait peut-être que les
deux
peuvent collaborer et c'est tout ce
qu'on peut espérer ça crée une nouvelle
forme de liberté non pas une liberté qui
est basé sur l'idée qu'elle s'arrête là
où commence celle des autres parce que
là on ce combat tous pour la liberté qui
est simplement une liberté qui permet
d'entreprendre ce que l'on envisage
simplement motivée par l'envié et que
cette liberté là eh ben ça peut nous
faire un nouveau modèle de société que
j'espère plus intelligent et à faire
ensemble
[Applaudissements]